era el 11 de marzo de 2020 así estaban
las principales calles de roma a la
capital de italia o las del epicentro
del cob y 19 en wuhan china los
supermercados no daban abasto y la
población temía que se acabasen las
existencias de papel higiénico no había
mascarillas que se reservaban para el
personal de salud
erigidos en héroes involuntarios las
escuelas cerraban y las bolsas se
desplomaban el virus llegaba a américa
latina'
ese dia panamá y bolivia declararon sus
primeros casos los eeuu prohibía viajes
con europa y la población mundial
quedaba aislada en su territorio y
muchas personas en su propia casa ese 11
de marzo la organización mundial de la
salud declaraba la pandemia mundial
estamos profundamente preocupados tanto
por los alarmantes niveles de
propagación y gravedad como por los
alarmantes niveles de inacción leve
action
we are there for me por lo tanto hemos
evaluado que el commit 19 se puede
caracterizar como una pandemia
caracteres de pandemic países de todo el
mundo ordenaban restricciones para dos
semanas las más largas de nuestras vidas
un año después el virus sigue activo con
alrededor de 118 millones de casos y más
de 2 millones y medio de fallecidos
primero fue china luego italia-españa
nueva york' y brasil el kobe 19 saturaba
hospitales de todo el mundo para después
reaparecer con fuerza en virulentas
nuevas olas y variantes los efectos del
coronavirus han llevado a las economías
a la peor crisis en décadas esto ha
derivado en protestas corrupción pobreza
y también en el surgimiento de un
negacionismo que ha agravado el curso de
la pandemia sin embargo también han
surgido olas de solidaridad que culminan
en una cooperación mundial histórica con
la que se ha conseguido desarrollar
vacunas en tiempo récord una señal de
esperanza para que el fin de la pandemia
esté cada día más cerca en un año
imposible de olvidar
[Música]